Je veux vous parler aujourd'hui de --
On m'a demandé de prendre une perspective à long terme, et je vais vous dire ce que
je considère comme les trois plus grands problèmes pour l'humanité
dans cette perspective à long terme.
Certains d'entre eux ont déjà été abordés par d'autres conférenciers,
ce qui est encourageant.
Il semble qu'il n'y ait pas qu'une seule personne
qui pense que ces problèmes sont importants.
Le premier, c'est -- la mort, un sacré problème.
Si vous regardez les statistiques,
elles ne nous sont pas très favorables.
Jusqu'à présent, la plupart des personnes qui ont vécu sont décédées.
À peu près 90 pour cent de tous ceux qui ont été en vie sont aussi morts à l'heure actuelle.
Ainsi, le taux de mortalité annuel s'élève à 150 000 --
pardon, le taux de mortalité quotidien -- 150 000 personnes par jour,
ce qui est indiscutablement un chiffre énorme.
Le taux de mortalité annuel est alors de 56 millions.
Si nous considérons la plus importante cause de mortalité -- le vieillissement --
elle concerne environ deux tiers de tous les humains qui meurent.
Ce qui nous donne par an un nombre de morts
plus important que la population du Canada.
Parfois, nous ne voyons pas un problème
parce qu'il est soit trop familier, soit trop important.
On ne peut pas le voir parce qu'il est trop gros.
Je pense que la mort doit être à la fois trop familière et trop importante
pour que la plupart des gens la perçoive comme un problème.
Quand on y pense, on peut voir que ce n'est pas d'un intérêt statistique.
Ce qui est -- voyons voir, combien de temps ai-je parlé?
J'ai parlé pendant trois minutes.
Ce qui signifie qu'environ 324 personnes sont mortes depuis que j'ai commencé à parler.
Un groupe comme -- c'est à peu près le nombre de personnes dans cette salle qui vient juste de mourir.
Le coût humain de cet événement est évident.
Une fois qu'on commence à y penser -- la souffrance, la perte --
c'est aussi, économiquement, un énorme gaspillage.
Je considère juste les informations, la connaissance et l'expérience
qui sont perdues en raison morts naturelles en général,
et du vieillissement, en particulier.
Supposez que nous assimilions une personne à un livre --
Bien entendu, c'est une sous-estimation.
L'apprentissage et l'expérience acquis au cours de la vie d'une personne
représentent bien plus que ce qu'on pourrait mettre dans un seul livre.
Mais supposons qu'on le fasse.
52 millions de personnes mourant de causes naturelles chaque année
cela correspond alors à 52 millions de volumes détruits.
La Bibliothèque du Congrès détient 18 millions de volumes.
Nous sommes contrariés par l'incendie de la bibliothèque d'Alexandrie.
C'est l'une des grandes tragédies
dont nous nous souvenons, encore aujourd'hui.
Mais c'est l'équivalent de trois Bibliothèques du Congrès --
complètement brûlées, perdues pour toujours -- chaque année.
Voici donc le premier grand problème.
Et je souhaite bonne chance à Aubrey de Grey,
et à d'autres peronnes comme lui,
pour tenter de faire quelque chose à ce propos dès que possible.
Le risque existentiel -- deuxième grand problème.
Le risque existentiel est une menace pour la survie humaine, ou pour le potentiel à long terme de notre espèce.
Alors, pourquoi suis-je en train de dire que c'est un grand problème?
Eh bien, regardons d'abord les probabilités --
c'est très très difficile à estimer --
mais il n'y a eu que quatre études là-dessus ces dernières années,
ce qui est surprenant.
On pourrait penser qu'il y a un certain intérêt
à essayer d'en apprendre plus à ce propos, étant donné l'importance des enjeux,
mais c'est un domaine qui est véritablement laissé de côté.
Il y a toutefois eu quatre études --
une par John Lesley, qui a écrit un livre à ce sujet.
Il a estimé la probabilité selon laquelle nous ne parviendrons pas
à survivre au vingt-et-unième siècle -- 50 pour cent.
De la même manière, l'Astronome royal, que nous avons entendu parler hier,
estime aussi la probabilité à hauteur de 50 pour cent.
Un autre auteur ne donne pas d'estimation chiffrée,
mais déclare que la probabilité d'échec est significative.
J'ai écrit un long article à ce sujet.
J'ai soutenu le fait qu'attribuer une probabilité inférieure à 20 pour cent serait une erreur
à la lumière des faits actuels dont nous disposons.
Certes, les chiffres donnés ici
doivent être interprétés avec prudence,
mais il semble se dégager un consensus selon lequel le risque est considérable.
Tous ceux qui se sont penchés sur la question sont d'accord là-dessus.
À présent, si nous nous intéressons à la réduction
de la probabilité de l'extinction humaine d'un seul pour cent --
ce n'est pas beaucoup -- cela représente 60 millions de vies sauvées,
si l'on prend en compte le nombre de personnes vivantes aujourd'hui, la génération actuelle.
Eh bien un pour cent de six milliards de personnes, ce sont donc 60 millions.
C'est un grand nombre.
Si nous devions prendre en compte les générations futures
qui ne verront jamais le jour dans l'hypothèse où nous nous faisons sauter,
cela donnerait un nombre gigantesque.
Si nous pouvions finalement coloniser une partie de l'univers --
le Superamas de la Vierge --
peut-être cela nous prendra-t-il 100 millions d'années pour nous y rendre,
mais si la race humaine s'éteint nous n'irons jamais là-haut.
Ainsi même une réduction d'un pour cent
du risque d'extinction pourrait mener
à ce nombre astronomique -- 10 puissance 32.
Alors en prenant en compte les générations futures aussi bien que la nôtre,
tout autre impératif moral de coût philanthropique perd simplement sa pertinence.
La seule chose sur laquelle il faudrait se concentrer
serait la réduction du risque existentiel
parce que même la plus petite diminution de ce risque
pourrait réduire à néant tout autre bénéfice que nous serions susceptibles de réaliser.
Et même en regardant uniquement la génération actuelle,
et en ignorant le potentiel qui serait perdu si nous devions disparaître,
cela serait toujours largement prioritaire.
À présent, laissez-moi utiliser le temps qu'il me reste à vous parler du troisième grand problème,
parce qu'il est plus subtil et peut-être plus difficile à saisir.
Vous souvenez-vous de ces moments dans votre vie --
peut-être certains ne les ont jamais connus - mais les autres,
je vous parle de ces moments que vous avez vécus
où la vie était fantastique.
Cela a pu se produire lors d'un instant de grande inspiration créative
que vous avez pu connaître en entrant dans cette salle.
Ou bien lorsque vous avez compris quelque chose pour la toute première fois
Ou peut-être dans l'extase d'un amour romantique.
Ou encore une expérience esthétique -- un coucher du soleil, une grande œuvre d'art.
De temps en temps nous vivons ces instants
et nous réalisons alors à quel point la vie peut être agréable.
Et vous vous demandez pourquoi cela ne peut pas être ainsi tout le temps ?
Vous désirez ardemment vous accrocher à ce bonheur.
Et alors, bien entendu, il vous échappe, vous retournez dans la vie ordinaire et le souvenir s'évanouit.
Et il est très difficile de se rappeler, dans un état d'esprit normal,
combien la vie peut être bonne dans ces meilleurs moments.
Ou à quel point elle peut être désagréable dans les pires.
Le troisième grand problème, c'est que la vie n'est pas systématiquement
aussi formidable qu'elle pourrait l'être.
Je crois que c'est vraiment un grand problème.
Il est facile de savoir ce que nous ne voulons pas.
Voici une liste de choses que nous ne voulons pas --
la maladie, la mort involontaire, la souffrance inutile, la cruauté,
une croissance stoppée, la perte de mémoire, l'ignorance, l'absence de créativité.
Supposez que nous remédions à ces choses-là -- que nous fassions quelque chose pour les combattre.
Que nous sortions vainqueurs.
Que nous nous débarrassions de tout cela.
Nous pourrions aboutir à quelque chose qui ressemble à ça.
Ce qui est -- je veux dire, c'est en réalité beaucoup mieux que ça.
Mais est-ce que c'est vraiment le mieux dont nous puissions rêver ?
Est-ce le maximum que nous pouvons faire ?
Ou bien est-il possible de trouver quelque chose d'un peu plus exaltant vers quoi se tourner ?
Et quand on y pense,
Je crois qu'il est évident qu'il existe des manières
de changer les choses, pas simplement en éliminant le négatif,
mais en ajoutant du positif.
Sur ma liste de souhaits figureraient au moins --
des vies plus longues, en meilleur santé, un bien-être subjectif plus important,
des capacités cognitives plus développés, davantage de connaissances et de compréhension,
un potentiel illimité d'épanouissement personnel
au-delà de nos limites biologiques actuelles, de meilleures relations,
un potentiel sans limites pour un développement
spirituel, moral et intellectuel.
Si nous souhaitons réaliser cela, qu'est-ce qui doit changer dans le monde ?
Eh bien voici la réponse -- nous devons changer.
Pas simplement le monde qui nous entoure, mais aussi nous-mêmes.
Pas juste la façon dont nous voyons le monde, mais notre manière d'être -- précisément notre biologie.
La nature humaine doit changer.
Quand on en vient à évoquer le changement de la nature humaine,
la première chose qui vient à l'esprit
ce sont ces technologies de modification de l'humain --
les hormones de croissance, la chirurgie esthétique,
les stimulants tels que la Ritalin, l'Adderall, les anti-dépresseurs,
les stéroïdes anabolisants, les cœurs artificiels.
C'est une liste plutôt pathétique.
Il s'agit de choses qui font beaucoup de bien à des personnes ciblées
qui souffrent de conditions spécifiques.
Mais pour la plupart des gens, elles n'ont aucun effet
quant à une transformation éventuelle de ce que c'est que d'être humain
Et elles paraissent aussi un petit peu --
la plupart des gens sentent que, oui, bien sûr,
il faut qu'il y ait des antidépresseurs pour les gens réellement déprimés.
Mais une sorte de nausée
résulte du fait qu'ils sont, d'une certaine manière, non naturels.
Il convient de se rappeler qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres
modifications et améliorations technologiques que nous utilisons.
Nous disposons de produits pour la peau, d'habits.
Autant que je sache, vous utilisez tous ces
technologies d'amélioration dans cette salle, donc c'est vraiment une bonne chose.
Les produits permettant d'agir sur l'humeur sont utilisés depuis des temps très anciens --
la caféine, l'alcool, la nicotine, l'amélioration du système immunitaire,
l'amélioration de la vision, l'anesthésie.
Cela nous paraît tout à fait usuel,
mais réfléchissez un instant à l'immense progrès que cela représente --
Par exemple, subir une opération avant l'invention de l'anesthésie, ce n'était pas une partie de plaisir.
Les contraceptifs, les produits cosmétiques et les techniques de reprogrammation du cerveau --
tout cela semble inquiétant.
Mais la distinction entre une technologie --
dont l'archétype serait le gadget --
et les autres moyens de changer et de redéfinir la nature humaine est assez subtile.
Ainsi, si vous réfléchissez à ce que signifie apprendre à compter ou à lire,
il s'agit en fait littéralement d'une réécriture de son propre cerveau.
Changer les micro-structures de son cerveau à mesure que l'on progresse.
Donc dans un sens large, nous n'avons pas besoin de considérer la technologie
seulement comme de petits gadgets, comme ces choses-là.
Mais même les institutions, les techniques,
les méthodes psychologiques, etcétéra.
Des formes d'organisation peuvent avoir un impact significatif sur la nature humaine.
En ce qui concerne l'avenir, il y a tout un panel de technologies
que nous sommes pratiquement sûrs de pouvoir développer tôt ou tard.
Nous ne savons absolument rien des échelles de temps mises en jeu par ces développements.
Mais nous savons qu'ils sont cohérents avec tout ce que nous connaissons
qu'il s'agisse de lois physiques, chimiques, etcétéra.
Il est possible de supposer,
en laissant de côté l'éventualité d'une catastrophe,
que tôt ou tard nous développerons toutes ces techniques.
Et rien qu'une partie de celles-ci suffirait
à transformer la condition humaine.
Regardons donc quelques-unes des dimensions de la nature humaine
qui semblent laisser mériter des améliorations.
La durée de vie est une chose importante et urgente,
parce que si vous ne vivez pas,
eh bien tout le reste perd vite de son intérêt.
Les capacités intellectuelles -- regardons cette partie,
qui se divise en de nombreuses sous-catégories --
la mémoire, la concentration, l'énergie mentale, l'intelligence, l'empathie.
Ce sont vraiment d'importantes choses.
L'une des raisons pour laquelle nous leur accordons de l'importance
est qu'elles nous permettent d'être meilleurs au moment de se confronter aux autres --
ce sont des biens placés.
Mais une autre explication --
précisément celle pour laquelle nous avons des raisons éthiques de rechercher ces choses --
c'est qu'elles ont également une valeur intrinsèque.
C'est tout simplement mieux d'être capable de comprendre davantage le monde qui nous entoure
ainsi que les gens avec lesquels nous communiquons,
et de nous rappeler ce que nous avons appris.
Les modalités et les facultés particulières.
Toutefois, l'esprit humain n'est pas un simple processeur d'informations unitaires.
Il possède au contraire de nombreuses capacités différentes, particulières et évoluées
qui remplissent des tâches spécifiques pour nous.
Parlons des choses que nous considérons normalement susceptibles de donner du sens à la vie --
la musique, l'humour, l'érotisme, la spiritualité, l'esthétique,
l'éducation et l'affection, les ragots, les discussions avec les gens.
Elles sont toutes vraisemblablement rendues possibles par un ensemble de circuits
dont nous, les humains, disposons,
mais dont une autre forme de vie intelligente pourrait ne pas bénéficier.
Nous avons simplement la chance de disposer d'une machinerie neurale appropriée
pour pouvoir comprendre et apprécier la musique.
Tout ceci rendrait possible, en principe, le fait d'être sensible à l'amélioration.
Certaines personnes possèdent de meilleures aptitudes musicales
et de meilleures dispositions à apprécier la musique que d'autres.
De même il est intéressant de réfléchir à ce que les autres choses sont --
alors si toutes ces choses permettent d'obtenir de grandes valeurs,
pourquoi devrions-nous penser que l'évolution nous a dotés
de toutes les modalités qui nous sont nécessaires
avec d'autres valeurs qui peut-être existent ?
Imaginez une espèce
qui n'eût pas à disposition une telle machinerie neurale pour traiter la musique.
Elle nous contemplerait avec perplexité
alors que nous serions en train d'écouter une magnifique interprétation,
comme celle que nous venons d'écouter -- parce que les gens font des mouvements stupides.
Ils s'ennuieraient beaucoup et ne pourraient pas comprendre ce qui nous enchantait.
Mais peut-être ont-ils une autre faculté, quelque chose de différent
qui nous semblerait de même irrationel,
mais en fait ils exploitent probablement une autre grande valeur possible ici.
Valeur à laquelle nous serions littéralement sourds.
On pourrait alors très bien penser à ajouter différentes
nouvelles capacités sensorielles et facultés mentales.
Une fonctionnalité corporelle, une morphologie et un sang-froid affectif.
Un bien-être subjectif plus important.
Être capable de passer du repos à l'activité --
être capable de ralentir lorsque c'est nécessaire, puis d'accélerer.
Capable d'exécuter ce type de va-et-vient plus facilement
Ce serait très habile de savoir faire ça --
Et plus facile d'atteindre l'état
d'immersion totale dans ce que vous êtes en train de faire.
L'application et la compassion.
La capacité de -- c'est une autre application intéressante
qui aurait d'importants problèmes de ramifications sociales.
Si vous pouviez réellement choisir de préserver votre relation romantique avec une personne,
sans qu'elle diminue avec le temps,
de telle manière qu'il n'y ait pas -- que l'amour ne s'évapore jamais contre votre volonté.
Ce n'est sans doute pas aussi difficile qu'il y paraît.
Il se pourrait bien qu'une simple hormone ou quelque chose d'autre puisse remplir cette fonction.
Ça a été fait avec des campagnols.
Vous pouvez techniquement rendre un campagnol des prairies monogame
bien qu'il soit naturellement polygame.
C'est juste un simple gène.
Il se pourrait que ce soit plus compliqué avec des humains, mais peut-être pas tant que ça.
Voici la dernière image que je voudrais --
Il nous faut maintenant utiliser le pointeur laser.
Une motivation possible pour nous, ici, consisterait en un mode de vie --
une manière d'être, d'expérimenter, de penser, de voir,
d'interagir avec le monde.
Dans le petit coin en bas, ici, nous disposons d'un petit sous-espace
provenant d'un espace plus grand accessible aux êtres humains --
aux êtres ayant les mêmes capacités biologiques que nous.
C'est une partie de l'espace accessible aux animaux --
car nous sommes des animaux, nous formons donc un sous-ensemble de ceci.
Et puis vous pouvez imaginer que l'on améliore les capacités humaines.
Vous pourriez alors expérimenter différents modes de vie
si vous étiez capables de rester en vie pendant, disons, 200 ans.
Vous pourriez alors vivre différentes sortes de vie et engranger des sagesses
qui sont tout simplement inaccessibles aux humains que nous sommes.
Donc, vous vous déplacez vers cette sphère plus grande
et vous pourriez continuer ce procédé et finalement
explorer de nombreux recoins de ce grand espace contenant différents modes de vie possibles.
Alors, pourquoi est-ce une bonne chose à faire ?
Eh bien, nous savons déjà que dans ce petit cercle humain ici,
il existe des modes de vie incroyablement magnifiques qui valent vraiment la peine --
la vie humaine est formidable dans ses meilleurs moments.
Il n'y a aucune raison de croire que dans cet espace bien plus grand
il n'y ait pas également des modes de vie extrêmement intéressants.
Peut-être certains seraient bien au-delà de nos capacités les plus folles,
même difficiles à imaginer ou à rêver.
Alors, pour remédier à ce troisième problème,
Je pense qu'il nous faut -- lentement, avec précaution, mesure et sagesse éthique --
développer les moyens qui nous permettront d'atteindre et d'explorer cet espace plus large.
Et trouver les grandes valeurs qui pourraient s'y cacher.
Merci.